si vous le voulez bien nous allons
commencer nous accueillons
ce matin trois représentants de la Cour
des comptes venu nous présenter
le rapport public thématique publié le 7
février dernier et intitulé comme vous
le voyez à l'écran université et
territoire il s'agit alors plus
précisément de Monsieur clémin
Clémentine un pardon qui est rapporteur
Monsieur Philippe Payet qui est
président de la section enseignement
supérieur et recherche et Monsieur
Philippe Rousseau qui est président de
la section enseignement scolaire
jeunesse et sport de la troisième
chambre et à qui je donnerai la parole
dans quelques instants messieurs nous
vous remercions d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation vous vous doutez que l'angle
territorial que vous avez retenu
intéresse tout particulièrement la haute
assemblée et et en particulier notre
commission la problématique de l'ancrage
territorial des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur a d'ailleurs
irrigué les travaux de la mission
d'information sur la condition de la vie
étudiante en France menée au printemps
2021 par notre ressembler sous la
présidence de notre collègue Pierre
ouzougas et dont j'étais le rapporteur
votre rapport dresse le constat général
d'un paysage universitaire marqué par de
nombreuses fracturistes territoriales
sociales ou juridique qui se sont
accentués depuis une dizaine d'années
face à ce diagnostic vous recommandez de
renouveler les modalités de pilotage et
d'allocation des moyens par l'État afin
qu'elle soit mieux adaptées aux
spécificités aux besoins et aux encrages
territoriaux de chaque établissement ce
faisant vous aboutissez un diagnostic
qui n'est pas loin d'une autre vous
pointez en particulier l'inégale
répartition des moyens selon les
universités vous soulevez la question de
l'appellation même d'université vous
faites le bilan des campus connectés où
vous appelez à une clarification du rôle
des recettes vis-à-vis de l'enseignement
supérieur autant de problématiques qui
sont au cœur de nos réflexions sur ce
secteur avant de vous céder la parole
pour une présentation plie détaillée
votre rapport et une présentation
visuelle également
de vos conseils de vos propositions je
me permets de vous rappeler que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat après votre
intervention luminaire notre rapporteur
sur les questions d'enseignement
supérieur Stéphane piennois vous posera
une première série de questions puis les
autres collègues qui le souhaiteront
interviendront également sans plus
tarder je vous donne la parole monsieur
Hayet pour commencer merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs merci beaucoup
de votre invitation nous en sommes très
honorés la cour est toujours honoré de
pouvoir présenter ses travaux devant
l'une de vos commissions je le suis dit
personnel parce que c'est la première
fois il imprime les fonctions récemment
que je me trouve devant vous et donc
nous allons essayer de répondre à vos à
vos attentes vous avez vous avez déjà
évoqué des travaux que vous aviez
réalisé je me permets de rappeler parmi
les travaux que nous avions présenté à
votre commission c'était il y a il deux
ans le rapport sur l'autonomie
financière d'université qui n'est pas en
lien avec notre sujet que nous avions
présenté à votre commission des finances
à l'automne demande 2019 quelques mots
et je céderai la parole à mon
prédécesseur et collègues Philippe
Rousselot quelques mots pour cadrer le
sujet mais vous le connaissez bien vous
savez qu'il existe environ 70 75
universités en France qui sont de taille
très variables de 2000 à 80 000 vous
savez que la population étudiante
globalement et 3 millions dont plus de
la moitié dans les universités au sens
strict
d'une population qui croit les
prévisions du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur font que les
îles de la population va croître toutes
choses légales par ailleurs jusqu'en
2025 vous savez également que la France
concent une dépense de son de son pi
pour l'enseignement supérieur qui est de
l'ordre de 6% qui est en dessous de la
moyenne de l'OCDE et en dessous de
l'Allemagne par exemple par comparaison
vous savez aussi évidemment même si nous
sommes pas la condition des finances que
cette dépense se concentre
principalement et c'est ce qui nous
intéresse nous au cours des comptes sur
la mission matériel avec ses 29
milliards et quelques de dépenses
budgétaires sans compter les dépenses
fiscales alors le sujet est bien celui
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président
c'est exactement de l'ancrage dans les
territoires puisque nos universités nos
ambitions mondiales les classements de
son en saison de classement vous pouvez
voir dans la presse ces jours-ci des
Genos de dire des ranking devant vous
mais des classements des universités
mais nous pensons aussi que il faut être
très attentif à la dimension
territoriale à l'ancrage pour des
raisons de débouchés pour des raisons de
de communauté territoriale et je vais
laisser évidemment mes collègues vous
présenter nos constats et nos
recommandations
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
peut-être faire tout d'abord
Philippe Bayet a eu de rappeler que
j'étais son professeur j'étais surtout
le contre rapporteur de de ce travail
ce travail qui vous est dont nous allons
parler aujourd'hui se situe dans le
sillage de la note dite d'enjeux
structurel que nous avions publié en
octobre 2022 et qui s'intitulait les
universités à l'horizon 2030 plus de
liberté plus de responsabilité si vous
avez cette note en mémoire
elle comme son nom l'indique elle
creusait le sillon de la question de
l'autonomie des universités est posée
plusieurs questions dans un format très
bref sur la relation avec les
territoires si bien que ce travail
finalement se situe dans la continuité
de ce premier travail il essaye d'en
documenter quelques orientations et de
d'en conforter la plupart même si
il nous a permis aussi de tempérer
quelques unes de nos observations
initiales
tout au début du lancement de cette
enquête nous pensions l'intitulé
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
et les territoires et devant la
vastitude du sujet nous avons décidé de
le restreindre à université et
territoires j'y reviendrai dans quelques
instants
je ne vais pas reprendre le fil de ce
travail c'est Clémentin qui qui le fera
mais vous avez vu que qui dit territoire
dit géographie et qui dit géographie
histoire et ça va ensemble et de ce fait
nous avons essayé de montrer comment
sans aller trop loin dans le détail
comment c'est
défini la territorialité progressivement
des universités avec dans le passé
récent la date charnière qui est
évidemment en 2007 la loi liberté est
responsabilité des universités et
finalement
une situation où on a du mal à se
retrouver entre la nécessité de garantir
un accès à l'enseignement supérieur
partout sur le territoire
et assurer aussi et assumer plus
exactement la situation des territoires
où le taux de couverture des universités
étaient très faibles nous avons parlé
avec des guillemets de désert
universitaire donc cet état des lieux
s'appuie sur une très vaste
documentation
naturellement parler de territoire c'est
aussi parler de
déconcentration nous avons donc fouillé
la piste de la déconcentration pour y
revenir tout à l'heure avec bien sûr la
question du de la relation entre les
rectorats et les universités qui dit
territoire dit décentralisation et nous
avons donc aussi
travailler en relation avec les
différentes collectivités sur les
questions qui peuvent les directement
les intéresser et enfin et pour la
première fois je crois nous avons
également
travaillé avec le secteur des
entreprises pour mieux assurer la
question de l'implantation des
universités dans leur tissus économique
alors un petit mot si vous le voulez
bien sur les modalités de réalisation de
cette enquête
toutes les universités ont été
questionnées ont reçu un questionnaire
le taux de réponse a été très
satisfaisant
plus de 65% des réponses très très
documentées chaque réponse fait parfois
plus de 100 pages
nous avons également
bénéficier d'un sondage auprès des
entreprises qui nous ont apporté
plus de 4 plus de 400 entreprises ont
répondu à ce sondage qui est à lui-même
assez fouillé et qui nous ont permis de
dresser une un premier tableau de la
perception il s'agit d'une perception
des entreprises vis-à-vis des
universités et enfin pour votre bonne
information sachez que
c'est une c'est un rapport qui a été
mené en un an mais son temps
opérationnel a commencé en février de
l'année dernière et c'est achevé au mois
de juillet entre juillet et décembre
date de la parution c'est le temps de la
procédure et de la contradiction
je voudrais insister auprès de vous pour
vous dire qu'il s'agit là d'un premier
pas et absolument pas d'un travail
définitif bien au contraire
nous n'avons pas tout vu pour des
raisons tout à fait pratique les
effectifs et le temps qui nous était
impartis il s'agit en vérité d'une
démarche d'ouverture et d'exploration
pour nos lecteurs mais aussi pour
nous-mêmes
nous avons laissé de côté des domaines
tout à fait fondamentaux tels que la
recherche et l'innovation tout le monde
a en tête la vallée de la chimie la
vallée de la cosmétique elle est
réussite dans le bois à Limoges ou
sur les hydrocarbures à Pau tout ça
on ne l'a pas fouillé
de même nous avons à peine effleuré la
notion d'impact
nous avons à peine effleuré la notion de
modélisation que nous aurions bien voulu
pouvoir mettre au point
et pour ne rien dire de la notion de la
question de l'immobilier universitaire
tout à fait centrale dans ce domaine
mais pour nous consoler nous avons
publié il y a peu un rapport
spécialement consacré à ce sujet il y a
quelques semaines
voilà pour terminer cette brève
présentation vous avez vu sans doute les
réponses qui ont été faites à ce travail
donc globalement la réponse de la
ministre madame Retailleau est plutôt
difficile je vais pas être pas de la
qualifier mais
ne conteste pas la plupart de nos de nos
observations et elle nous annonce que
l'esprit de ce rapport se trouve en
partie traduit par la réflexion qui est
en cours actuellement au sein du
ministère et notamment par la mise en
place des camps les contrats d'objectifs
et de moyens et de performance
vous aurez sans doute aussi vu les
réponses
des collectivités alors
sachez aussi que nous avions auditionné
France université et que France
université a publié un communiqué
qui donne un élément satisfaction
globale mais qui regrette deux choses la
première c'est qu'on ne soit pas aller
assez loin dans la question de
l'autonomie ce qui me paraît
voilà un peu un peu rapide parce que
précisément c'est pas parce qu'on ne
prononce pas le mot à toutes les trois
phrases que quand on en parle pas et
qu'on avait avec la nôtre précédente que
je vous indiquais tout à l'heure déjà
largement fouillé cette question et elle
regrette que nous ne prenions pas assez
le mot évaluation et qu'on ne le traite
pas assez ça c'est vrai c'est d'ailleurs
une idée qui a été reprise par le hcres
dans un communiqué publique qui lui-même
pense que au cœur de toutes les
solutions se trouvent l'évaluation
prend beaucoup et pour terminer
nous avons eu pas mal de presse sur sur
ce rapport qui a donné lieu à des
échanges de tiers entretien et un débat
voilà monsieur le Président si vous
permettez on pourrait donner le même
dans la parole à Clément Hénin qui en 15
minutes environ va
parcourir les principales observations
de ce travail après quoi nous serons à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
[Musique]
donc la course est intéressée à cette
dans cette enquête au lien entre
l'université et les acteurs territoriaux
et plus généralement entre les liens
entre l'université et les territoires
donc comme la précisé monsieur Rousselot
nous nous sommes focalisés pour ce
rapport sur les liens entre en fait
l'université entre l'enseignement
supérieur et les territoires on a donc
laissé de côté
à contrecoeur la question de la de la
recherche
donc le premier constat qu'on peut qu'on
peut percevoir c'est celui des
disparités géographiques dans l'accès
enseignement supérieur donc vous voyez
sur le transparent ici le taux de
diplômé chez les chez les 25 34 ans et
on voit que ce tour en fait décroît
assez naturellement à mesure qu'on
s'éloigne des grandes villes il est
paraît aussi de façon assez clair que la
présence d'un établissement
d'enseignement supérieur fait augmenter
ce taux de façon de façon assez locale
ce qui était une fois de plus des liens
entre les politiques d'aménagement du
territoire et les politiques de
l'enseignement supérieur
alors alors que que cette carte fait
apparaître toutes les universités sur un
pied d'égalité en réalité le premier
constat de la cour c'est que le concept
même d'université qui a été très
longtemps protégé est aujourd'hui éclaté
dans des réalités très diverses
donc les établissements qui partagent le
titre d'université non plus grand chose
en commun alors déjà ces universités
héritent de disparité historiques
marquée en matière de finances en
matière de profil étudiant et surtout en
matière de place de la recherche et
c'est disparités ont été récemment
accentués par diverses mesures dont les
investissements d'avenir qui ont cherché
à créer 10 à 20 universités d'excellence
en recherche par des procédures
sélectives alors ce que ce que montre
notre enquête c'est que pour la plupart
les petites universités donc ce qu'on
appelle une petite université c'est
université qui a environ 20 000
étudiants ou moins non plus ne sont plus
en mesure de capter ces financements
sélectifs pour mener leurs recherches
dans l'ensemble des disciplines
alors pour prendre en compte ces
disparités les universités ont entrepris
de se classer via des associations donc
on a par exemple l'Association des
universités de recherche françaises
l'Association des universités de
recherche et de formation les petites ou
moyennes universités
qui attestent bien de ces disparités
plus récemment la création plutôt la
possibilité de créer des établissements
publics expérimentaux prévues par
l'ordonnance de 2018 ordonnance Vidal
concrétise juridiquement ces disparités
entre établissement alors dans ce
contexte la Cour constate que le
dispositif d'allocations des moyens du
ministère n'a pas évolué pour prendre en
compte ses réalités donc c'est un
dispositif qui est très centralisé qui
ne prend pas en compte la qualité des
formations ni le territoire occupé à
l'origine c'est ce qu'on appelait le
système sympa qui a été progressivement
complexifié auquel est ajouté le
dialogue stratégique et de gestion puis
des dispositions spécifiques
issues de la loi de programmation de la
recherche bref le système a fini par
devenir complètement illisible pour les
premières concernées c'est à dire pour
les universités
donc pour sortir de cette situation la
cour propose deux scénarios le premier
scénario c'est une catégorisation des
établissements fondés sur des critères
objectifs comme le nombre d'étudiants la
place de la recherche la Cour s'est
essayée à cet exercice et a publié non
pas une catégorisation mais plusieurs
catégorisations en fonction des grandes
missions des universités qui sont
disponibles dans le rapport et la
deuxième option elle prend plutôt la
forme d'un dialogue individualisé sur la
base de contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens et la cour recommande que cette
option pourrait passer davantage par les
services déconcentrés de l'État
quoi qu'il en soit la cour émine
recommandation celui d'instituer un
nouveau modèle d'allocation des moyens
reposant sur des critères d'activité de
l'établissement prenant en compte
l'environnement territorial alors sur un
sujet moins structurant mais toutefois
important la cour à constaté au cours de
son enquête que le titre d'université
était insuffisamment protégé puisque des
établissements privés utilisent alors
que le code de l'éducation l'interdit
la Cour constate également que les
titres de diplôme notamment licence et
master sont insuffisamment protégés
également des établissements privés par
des stratégies de conventionnement
permettent de délivrer ces titres qui
sont normalement réservés aux
universités
donc tout cela participe à une confusion
entre le public et le privé et ça peut
participer aussi à des situations de
concurrence que nous avons à tester
entre les établissements publics
alors dans un contexte où les
établissements privés se développent
extrêmement rapidement la cour
recommande au ministère d'être un peu
plus de veiller un peu mieux au respect
de ces dénominations dans l'intérêt
premier des étudiants bien sûr
alors au-delà de ces constats généraux
sur l'état des universités la Cour a
voulu s'intéresser aux enjeux
territoriaux des missions d'enseignement
supérieur et de vie étudiantes à travers
les exemples des antennes des campus
connectés des CROUS alors tout d'abord
les antennes donc
l'équipe des rapporteurs a été surprise
de se rendre compte qu'il n'existait pas
de définition du ministère de ce qu'est
une antenne donc la cour du proposer une
définition d'une antenne et s'appuyer
sur cette définition pour analyser les
antennes et leurs étudiants donc la Cour
a décompter 150 sites secondaires
d'enseignement supérieur qui accueille
91.000 étudiants et environ les trois
quarts qui sont en premier cycle donc
c'est surtout du premier cycle et un
tiers dans les IUT et ces antennes
accueillent tout de même 11% des néo
bacheliers ce qui en fait un acteur
important de l'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur
ces lieux accueillent davantage
d'étudiants ruraux et
issus de famille défavorisées avec une
réussite qui est similaire à celle du
siège mais un taux de poursuite en
second cycle qui est en revanche plus
faible
la Cour a également analysé le coût de
ses antennes universitaires et nous
avons été surpris que le coût d'un
étudiant en antenne est similaire voire
légèrement inférieur au coût d'un
étudiant dans le siège mais ce coût est
toutefois toujours perçu comme un coup
supplémentaire
donc la cour recommande au ministère de
reconnaître ses antennes en proposant
notamment une définition puis et de
mieux les évaluer pour appréhender la
dimension territoriale dans le calcul de
la subvention pour charge du service
public le ministère ne peut pas se
cacher éternellement vers l'autonomie de
l'établissement sur une question aussi
centrale que les antennes
alors une autre proposition pour
rapprocher les formations des étudiants
c'est celle des campus connectés alors
c'est qu'en plus connecté ils ont été
lancés en 2019 et il s'agit de lieux
d'enseignement supérieur à distance donc
c'est un petit peu paradoxal c'est un
lieu d'enseignement à distance en
pratique cela passe par de la mise à
disposition de matériel informatique et
du tutorat
donc c'est qu'en plus connecté ont été
financés par le troisième volet des
programmes d'investissement d'avenir et
par les collectivités territoriales il y
en a eu il y en avait 87 en 2022 ils ont
accueilli 1015 étudiants à la rentrée
2022 donc la cour après son enquête la
course interroge sur la pertinence de
ces campus connectés sachant que le coût
annuel pour un étudiant est estimé à
13000 euros ce qui est considérable et
ce coup pour monter jusqu'à 110 000
euros pour un seul étudiant dans les
deux campus qui n'ont ont accueilli un
seul cette année
donc la cour recommande d'établir
rapidement un bilan de ces campus et le
ministère c'est d'orge est déjà engagé à
le faire dès 2023
au-delà des questions au-delà des
questions de formation les liens entre
le territoire les établissements pour
les questions de la vie étudiante
méritent également qu'on s'y attarde
donc tout d'abord la cour rejoint le
constat qui avait été fait par d'autres
notamment l'inspection générale des
finances de l'absence d'une définition
de direction claire au niveau national
sur ce que recouvre concrètement la vie
étudiante ce qui peut conduire dans le
contexte de l'autonomie des
établissements à des niveaux
d'implication extrêmement différents
alors un dispositif en particulier
intéressé la cour c'est celui du schéma
directeur de la vie étudiante qui est
prévu par la loi de 2013 donc c'est la
loi dite de fiorazo et qui oblige les
établissements à se coordonner
localement sur les questions de la vie
étudiante alors si l'initiative est
louable la Cour constate ici on ne
faisant quasiment que remonter
simplement les retours des universités
que le schéma directeur pourrait être
plus efficace en se concentrant sur les
partenariats les plus fréquents ce qui
revient en fait à passer d'une échelle
régionale à une échelle plutôt
métropolitaine voire départementale dans
certains cas
donc enfin on peut pas parler de vie
étudiante sans aborder la question des
centres régionaux des œuvres
universitaires et scolaires les CROUS
donc les CROUS restent l'acteur central
de la vie étudiante notamment sur les
thématiques du logement de la
restauration et des bourses
la courge qu'un rapprochement des CROUS
et des universités pourraient
représenter de nombreux avantages
notamment la création d'un guichet
unique pour les étudiants ce qui est une
demande de leur part et une meilleure
coordination sur le terrain il y a
quelques exemples qu'on peut visiter là
l'aménagement des horaires de cours pour
diminuer la file d'attente dans les
restaurants universitaires ou la
question des logements vacants pendant
la période estivale
toutefois après avoir interrogé les
universités directement sur cette
question la Cour constate que les
universités sont globalement opposées
donc il y a 65% des réponses qui sont
défavorables à un rapprochement entre
les CROUS et les universités donc une
montée en puissance progressive des
universités sur la question de la vie
étudiante paraît préférable toutefois un
rapprochement titre expérimental sur les
universités qui sont d'accord pourraient
être envisagés pour tester ses idées
alors il est difficile de de parler de
territoire sans mentionner bien sûr le
rôle des collectivités territoriales et
des services déconcentrés de l'État
alors
alors que l'enseignement supérieur a
longtemps été considéré comme une
compétence exclusivement régalienne
aujourd'hui les collectivités
territoriales sont des alliés précieuses
elles financent pour 1,5 milliards
d'euros l'enseignement supérieur et la
recherche
67% de ses financements sont portés par
les régions et environ un quart par les
intercommunalités et les communes
la Cour a constaté que
la Cour a constaté que les régions qui
sont pourtant chef de fil en matière
d'enseignement supérieur et recherche
depuis la loi neutre mène souvent de
leur propre politique sans pleinement
assurée ou pouvoir assurer la bonne
coordination avec l'ensemble des autres
collectivités territoriales cette
absence de coordination conduit à des
répartitions perfectibles voire dans
certaines situations d'être dispersions
des financements qui sont préjudiciaires
donc le meacer peine à associer les
collectivités territoriales dans
l'exercice de contractualisation qu'il
mène tous les cinq ans donc il s'agit
des fameux contrats quinquennaux malgré
les récents dispositions de la LPR qui y
invite
la Cour estime qu'une réforme de
l'organisation du mésr est nécessaire
pour pouvoir pleinement exercer son rôle
de stratège et mieux prendre en compte
les spécificités du territoire donc
allons dans ce sens la fonction de
réacteur délégué à l'esprit a été créé
dans certaines régions et pas dans
toutes les régions en 2020 afin de
faciliter le dialogue avec les
universités
toutefois la cour regrette que le rôle
et les missions confiées à ses réacteurs
délégués ne sont pas clairement établis
ce qui peut conduire à des situations
très variables notamment ils n'ont pas
la pleine délégation de la part des
réacteurs de région académiques qui
restent les chanceliers des universités
donc la cour recommande de clarifier la
place et le rôle de ces réacteurs
enfin
la Cour a souhaité étudier pour la
première fois comme le souligner
monsieur Rousselot les liens entre les
universités et le monde économique les
universités des entreprises alors tout
d'abord le la Cour a remarqué que
certaines universités ont lancé des
évaluations ou des études d'impact qui
visent à mesurer l'impact économique des
universités sur leur territoire
l'impact économique des universités sur
leur territoire afin de
mesurer en quelque sorte quel est le
retour sur investissement de l'argent
public mis dans l'enseignement supérieur
donc cette ces initiatives sont louables
et pourrait notamment permettre de
faciliter les négociations budgétaires
pour ces établissements alors la cour
recommande d'établir un cadre
méthodologique national pour pouvoir
apprécier ces impacts de façon
comparable et notamment avoir un impact
global à l'échelle du pays
enfin
les acteurs du monde économique
s'affirment de plus en plus comme des
interlocuteurs essentiels des
universités les chefs d'entreprise
participent au conseil d'administration
à différents conseils pédagogiques ce
qui contredit l'image historique qu'on
peut avoir d'université qui est très
éloignée des entreprises et qui n'est
plus entièrement vrai
pour s'en rendre compte de façon plus
objective la cour à réaliser un sondage
auprès de plus de 400 chefs
d'entreprises en partenariat avec CCI
France et ce sondage a fait apparaître
qu'une majorité des chefs d'entreprise
souhaiteraient être davantage associé et
informé sur l'offre de formation ça
c'est un peu plus précise on a 70% des
dirigeants interrogés qui pensent ne pas
être suffisamment informés sur l'offre
de formation des universités les plus
proches de chez eux
le sondage montre aussi que un tiers des
dirigeants souhaitent être
de pouvoir davantage influer sur les
évolutions de l'offre de formation et
20% voudrait être mieux intégrés dans
les parcours universitaires
la plupart des chefs d'entreprise
déplore également un manque de
réactivité dans la construction et
l'agrément des diplômes donc
c'est trop long et trop difficile de
créer un nouveau diplôme et pour
notamment pour répondre à cette question
la cour recommande une expérimentation
qui permettrait aux échelons académiques
au rectorat de d'intervenir dans les
procédures d'accréditation afin de les
rendre plus réactifs et de mieux prendre
en compte les spécificités territoriales
je vous remercie pour votre attention et
on a votre disposition pour les
questions merci
rapport comme je le disais qui recouvre
des des
un certain nombre de points que nous
avions nous même mais examiné dans la
mission d'information mais qui ouvre
aussi de nouvelles pistes et c'est je
suis sûr que mes collègues vont
intervenir justement sur ces nouvelles
pistes et on va commencer par Stéphane
piennois notre rapporteur sur les
crédits budgétaires de l'enseignement
supérieur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
merci pour cette présentation d'un
travail
à la coutumée fouillée et transversale
sur l'implantation
territoriale des universités dans leur
diversité vous avez insisté en préalable
sur les différentes phases de
construction et d'implantation des
univers de création des universités sur
notre territoire juste sur l'utilisation
et le l'exploitation l'appropriation du
titre université lui-même dans votre
propos tout à l'heure je pense qu'il est
ce que vous vouliez dire c'est que il
convient de différencier les universités
privées qui ont acquis ce titre avant la
loi de 1880 et celle qui l'ont acquis
après je pense que pour que les choses
soient tout à fait claires
première partie de mes observations de
mes de mes questions vous dressez
finalement un constat assez sévère du
pilotage de l'État par l'état du paysage
universitaire et votre rapport à vite
finalement à
à une réflexion systémique sur les
universités leur mission leur
fonctionnement incluant le sujet central
du financement notamment évidemment par
les subventions pour charges de service
public mais pas que également par les
pays a qui ont vu sur vos graphiques
sont j'allais dire accaparer en tout cas
très très concentré sur les universités
de grande taille premier point donc
l'évolution de cette contractualisation
entre l'État et les universités
actuellement en cours fournit une
nouvelle opportunité si j'ose dire
estimez-vous que la création des comp
des contrats d'objectifs de moyens et de
performance et cette solution est la
solution pour permettre une meilleure
allocation des moyens en tenant compte
donc de la des singularités des sites
des universités et cet outil qui est
aujourd'hui expérimenté auprès de
quelques grandes universités doit-il
être étendu à toutes les catégories à
l'ensemble des catégories d'universités
dans leur grande diversité comme je l'ai
dit précédemment votre rapport ne
s'engage pas beaucoup sur la question de
l'autonomie vous êtes revenus là-dessus
effectivement sans vous demander de
citer ce terme tous les toutes les trois
lignes c'est pourtant directement lié à
votre à votre étude pourquoi cette
ce manque de focus disons sur
l'autonomie des universités quelle forme
pourrait prendre selon vous une relation
une nouvelle relation refondée entre le
ministère et ses services déconcentrés
et les établissements
sur les antennes universitaires vous
dresser un bilan plutôt favorable sur
ces antennes universitaires alors avec
la une terminologie qui reste affiner ce
que le terme d'antenne est plutôt perçu
péjorativement mais d'abord avec des
résultats académiques qui sont tout à
fait comparables avec ceux des
universités mères et un coup estimatif
inférieur quoique assez approximatif si
j'ai bien compris ce qu'on a pas de
on n'a pas véritablement de de
d'outils pour mesurer ça de manière plus
précise mais en revanche une poursuite
d'études en deuxième cycle assez faible
quels sont selon vous les raisons de ces
singularités et les freins éventuels au
déploiement de ces antennes sur d'autres
parties du territoire
concernant la vie étudiante vous pointez
l'insuffisance de la coordination entre
les CROUS et les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur
particulièrement dans le domaine du du
logement et de la restauration qui a été
mis en lumière si je puis dire avec les
crises les dernières crises qu'elles en
sont les raisons vous recommander
également de renforcer la responsabilité
des universités en évoquant même une
hypothèse de rapprochement administratif
c'était votre dernier point tout à
l'heure entre les CROUS et les
universités mais toutefois rejeté par
une majorité d'entre elles en quoi se
rapprochement selon vous serait
bénéfique et l'écrousse ils sont ils
favorables j'ai cru comprendre que non
dans leur très grande majorité
et enfin votre rapport ainsi sur la
nécessité de mieux orienter l'offre de
formation vers les attentes du monde
économique une interaction entre ces
deux ces deux mondes pourtant au niveau
territorial de nombreuses universités
sont déjà engagées sur cette dans cette
démarche d'interaction considérez-vous
qu'il manque une impulsion voire une
coordination à l'échelon nationale de à
l'initiative du ministère de cette
interaction je vous remercie
budgétaires sur la recherche oui merci
monsieur le Président merci messieurs
votre rapport ne traite pas directement
de la mission de recherche des
universités pourtant l'important sous
nom de celle-ci participe à la
catégorisation des des établissements
certaines universités conduisent à une
recherche
pluridisciplinaire de premier ordre au
niveau mondial je suis élu du plateau de
Saclay donc voilà je parle aussi à
chaque fois
j'embête mes collègues avec
avec cette fierté chauvine alors que
d'autres se concentrent sur un champ de
recherche particulier voire uniquement
sur leur mission de formation le nouveau
modèle d'allocation des moyens que vous
appelez de vos vœux doit-il aussi
obtenir compte de l'activité de
recherche de ces université si oui sous
quelle forme et qu'elle devrait être
selon vous à ce moment-là le rôle des
recettes délégués à l'esprit en matière
de politique de recherche au niveau des
territoires merci
je vais vous laisser répondre à ces deux
premières questions et puis après je
donnerai la parole aux autres collègues
qui l'ont souhaité
comment vous vous répartissez
[Musique]
alors je vais essayer monsieur le
sénateur de reprendre dans l'ordre et
madame la sénatrice également pour ce
qui alors vous nous dites que on a
peut-être pas assez parlé de la notion
d'autonomie moi je pense qu'on en parle
tout le temps parce que l'autonomie vu
par nous c'est un tout
ce n'est pas une question simplement
financière ou juridique c'est la
capacité pour l'université d'être global
si je peux en playlist parce que non pas
sous la forme de l'anglicisme qui
voudrait dire mondial non mais
globaliser sur un ensemble de fonctions
dont la vie étudiante dont la formation
dont la recherche dont les relations
avec le tissu économique
le comp est-il le bon outil
nous le dira mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que dans le passé la Cour des
comptes n'a cessé de demander
la mise en point de comme le P nous
paraît un petit peu
parfait à toi en tout état de cause des
comes sous la condition
Express que le M
soit contractuel c'est à dire que les
universités puissent dans ce document
disposer d'une vision pluriannuelle des
moyens sous la forme principale des SCSP
des moyens qui leur seront alloués afin
de précisément donner un sens
stratégique à ce contrat
donc ce que nous demandons dans le
contraste c'est que
il soit aussi
après c'est une affaire technique quels
sont les bons indicateurs quels sont
quel est l'énoncé le plus judicieux pour
les objectifs ça c'est de la technique
je dirais d'un deuxième ordre ce qui est
fondamental c'est que ce soit un contrat
que se passe-t-il si les clauses ne sont
pas respectées
ce qui importe c'est qu'il soit plus
réelle que il soit que les moyens soient
très clairement engagés sous une forme
contractuelle avec que se passe-t-il si
les clauses de son pas respectées aussi
dans ce domaine donc pour tout vous dire
pour nous le COM est un outil qui sous
ses conditions nous paraît de nature à
entraîner des progrès car
la relation financière avec entre l'État
l'université devient plus singulière
plus concentré sur ce qu'est
l'université en question qu'elle soit
grande petite moyenne littorale
montagnarde ou tout ce que urbaine
ce que nous pensons c'est qu'aujourd'hui
chaque relation contractuelle entre le
ministère
et université doit être
singularisé à ce qu'est cette même
université on ne peut pas faire le même
travail pour une université de 100 000
étudiants qui sera bientôt le on y
arrivera bientôt à Lille par exemple ou
à Marseille et Université de 3000
étudiants comme il en existe aujourd'hui
des universités
est-ce que nous disons aussi dans ce
rapport c'est que le COM qui ne doit pas
être que un outil financier répète il
doit être la traduction d'une stratégie
locale doit intégrer le phénomène
territorial tel que nous l'avons
commencé à le survoler et aller ce qui
s'est dans ce travail
[Musique]
sur les antennes pourquoi pourquoi
se déficit de seconde cycle
c'est sans doute parce que jusqu'à
présent la le second cycle reste la
spécialité de la maison mère si je puis
employer cette expression vis-à-vis des
antennes
parce que les professeurs et les maîtres
de conférence qui
pilote les masters et les doctorats sont
moins mobiles alors on en trouve bien
entendu qui font le déplacement mais ça
reste dans l'ordre d'un tiers des
professeurs ou des enseignants
chercheurs et de ce fait
c'est une sorte de contrat moral qui
s'est installée entre l'étudiant et son
université il fait son premier cycle
dans une antenne et il sera appelé à
faire le second dans l'université mer ça
reste à discuter bien entendu mais là
encore je me méfierai personnellement de
d'une recommandation générale sur ce
point je pense que c'est à chaque
université d'étudier de près
l'opportunité qu'il y aurait pour elle
de
décentrer son deuxième cycle vers des
antennes
ce qui aurait évidemment pour bénéfice
d'éviter aux étudiants un déplacement
qui peut dans certains cas s'avérer
compliqué
donc sur l'écrou ce
l'histoire c'est que nous avions tenté à
la cour de lancer une idée un peu forte
dans cette note structurelle dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure où nous
lancions l'idée de dans cette optique
que j'ai décrivais à l'instant de
l'université globale l'université campus
que le campus existe ou pas
naturellement en tant que entité
physique il ne pense que nous pensions
que l'autonomie c'était aussi la
capacité pour les étudiants pour les
universités de piloter complètement la
vie de l'étudiant et à ce titre de
pouvoir intégrer
les dispositifs actuellement plus
spécialisés sur l'hébergement et la
restauration et certaines formes d'aides
que sont les CROUS à l'occasion de la
contradiction de cette note c'est le
knos qui avait
émis des réserves très très fortes
ce qui était tout à fait je dirais dans
son rôle en revanche nous avions été
les autres acteurs du monde de l'essr
avait réservé un accueil
soit favorable soit ouvert en tout cas
pas négatif à cette idée et donc notre
surprise dans le cadre de ce rapport a
été lorsque nous sommes allés au contact
des présidents d'universités de nous
rendre compte que il ne se sentent pas
prêts je pense pas qu'il y a une
opposition idéologique ou théorique ou
quelque soit c'est que en vérité ils ne
se sentent pas encore prêts pour
assumer cette charge
dans la cour a montré les limites
mais qui c'est vrai dans la vie
quotidienne peut aussi largement suffire
aux
universités donc l'idée de la course
c'est que on laisse vivre cette idée on
en fait plus du tout une recommandation
une perspective d'avenir on la laisse
vivre en laissant un chacun
éventuellement comme il disait Clément
Hénin tout à l'heure la possibilité
de l'expérimenter c'est une idée qui
avait reçu le soutien de France
université de manière explicite et
écrite il y a un an et demi et c'est une
idée qui reçoit aussi un accueil
favorable chez un bon tiers des
universités
orienter la formation vers le monde
économique
les universités ont beaucoup changé
j'ai commencé à m'y intéresser il y a
une quinzaine d'années et je dois dire
que en 15 ans je les ai vus de venir
autre
sous l'effet de diverses divers
phénomènes les lois les
changements sociologiques bien sûr et
démographiques mais elles ont de plus en
plus pris à leur charge des notions qui
auparavant étaient très secondaires et
notamment la relation avec le tissu
économique aujourd'hui dans certaines
universités est une priorité donc on va
pas dire qu'on ça qu'on est dans un dans
un désert d'idée loin de là bien au
contraire beaucoup de dynamisme ce que
nous remarquons par contre c'est le
résultat de la consultation que nous
avons menée avec chef d'entreprise et
cette consultation nous dit que
il y a toujours une différence entre
faire des efforts
quand ils sont trop
à sens unique
il faut que les chefs d'entreprise
soient appelés soient happé dans le
monde de l'université pour participer
c'est ce qu'il demande à la définition
de certaines formations et des finitions
du bassin d'emploi et à la définition de
l'insertion professionnelle en tant que
stratégie
je pense pour ma part que la présence
des chefs d'entreprise dans les conseils
d'administration n'est pas encore au bon
niveau
en nombre
et que c'est un domaine sur lequel on
pourrait sans doute te faire des progrès
et de quel chef d'entreprise parle-t-on
parce que on n'est pas du tout dans la
même configuration stratégique selon que
l'on parle à des PME des ETI ou des plus
grandes entreprises
et ce que nous pensons également
monsieur le sénateur c'est que vous
parliez de la place de l'État dans ce
questionnement
nous sommes quand même assez étonnés de
voir qu'il n'existe pas aujourd'hui une
méthode et une incitation à calculer
l'impact économique d'une université
alors certaines le font de leur propre
chef en passant par des cabinets plus ou
moins spécialisés disons spécialisés qui
produisent des travaux forcément
intéressants puisque ils sont uniques en
leur genre mais qui ne sont pas contre
expertisé qui ont des conclusions
parfois très étonnantes
très encourageantes très positive
naturellement mais qui ne aucun oubliés
à la même méthode et ils sont encore
très éparpillés sur le territoire et
finalement très rare de ce fait c'est un
sujet qui reste un petit peu en jachère
et je crois que c'est un sujet pareil
une incitation de l'État par un outil
méthodologique général et un
questionnement général serait
la bienvenue enfin je vais prendre si
vous permettez maintenant les
questionnements de la nationalité
donc c'est un sujet que sur lequel nous
avons fait l'impasse
le CEMP doit-il tenir compte de
l'activité de recherche
la réponse est mille fois oui
par contre au risque de vous décevoir je
suis pas tout à fait certain de ce que
ce sera nous on en a pas eu sous les
yeux
que faut-il pour que le comte tienne
compte de la recherche
je reviens sur ce que je disais à
l'instant c'est qu'ici nos contrats
et qui en définit l'architecture
est-ce que le contrat et la traduction
d'une stratégie locale y a-t-il une
stratégie de la recherche dans
l'université y ou x celle-ci était
validée et par qui
alors malheureusement je ne veux surtout
pas botter en touche sur une question
aussi importante mais nous n'avons pas
les comme pour l'instant le peu
d'information dans nos disposons ne nous
permet pas de vous faire une réponse
franche par contre la réponse est assez
catégorique pour la cour il faut
impérativement que la recherche
universitaire
la recherche soit intégrer dans le camp
parce que même s'ils ont fait l'impasse
dans ce travail présent en nous
focalisant sur enseignement supérieur
recherche et territoire ses capitales
je ne vous apprends rien et je ne
développe pas davantage donc si jamais
la recherche ne devait pas faire partie
de des comptes ou en être une partie
relativement secondaire et accessoire ce
serait un très dommage voilà et oui
vas-y fini déjà presque terminé oui
vous nous avez aussi questionné la
dessinatrice sur le rôle du recteur
délégué
il n'y en a pas partout
premier constat deuxième constat la
situation est très variée ou plus être
variable
nous avons rencontré des délégués esprit
qui ont pris en main leur dossier
nous avons rencontré d'autres qui sont
plus à la peine
en règle générale l'explication vient du
recteur qui délègue un peu beaucoup ou
pas du tout
et donc d'où notre développement et
notre recommandation
là vraiment face à la situation que nous
avons rencontrées et
il faut une doctrine et il faut
clarifier le rôle de cet acteur
d'autant plus que
il y a un potentiel de réussite
si jamais les universités peuvent
disposer d'un artelocuteur bien désigné
bien identifié qui dispose à ses côtés
du Drarry
donc le délégué régional à la recherche
et l'innovation
qui peut former un tandem très efficace
enseignement supérieur et recherche nous
on est on est plutôt ouvert à l'idée
qu'il y a un acteur déconcentré
spécialisé sur le monde universitaire et
surtout
qui se constitue comme interlocuteur
privilégié et enfin qui soit capable de
décider de quelque chose alors de
quelque chose au pluriel aussi bien dans
le domaine de la RH de la créditation
des financements du CPE et de tout ce
que l'on voudra voilà madame triste
rapidement en quelques points pour
éclairer par les travaux en cours ce que
vient de dire mon collègue Rousselot en
sortant de l'intégralité évidemment des
points qui viennent d'être évoqué sur le
mission d'université il est clair que
vous le savez l'université tiennent ces
missions de la loi dont bien entendu la
formation dont bien entendu la recherche
et dont bien entendu l'insertion
professionnelle et donc c'est au regard
avec des pondérations différentes de ces
missions je ne nécessite pas toutes bien
sûr que il faut apprécier la performance
la contractualisation d'université sur
les comptes évidemment la cour fait du
travail a posteriori et donc vous avez
vu comme comme nous l'annonce de la
première vague de compte les 34 premier
contrats l'administration nous dit qui
ne seront pas signés à valent rentrée
universitaire donc les premiers effets
les premiers contrats il faudra attendre
quelques mois nous avons déjà et je vous
en informe en prenant des risques prévus
un audit flash sur les comptes mais il
faudra attendre le début de l'année
prochaine voilà on ira voir la première
vague probablement et on pourra vous
rendre compte comme aux citoyens de ce
qui se passe enfin les comptes et vous
vous êtes il y a ici des spécialistes
des mines spécialistes du du budget de
l'enseignement supérieur vous
une partie de importante des budgets
étudiants qui est la question du
logement étudiant donc la Cour va
travailler ce logement étudiant sans
pouvoir produire avant l'année prochaine
sur les questions
je n'en vient pas sur la question de
d'insertion professionnelle
sur la question de la recherche je me
permets de y aller quelques productions
qui éclaireront de manière microscopique
enfin microéconomique
la question nous allons sortir dans le
sortir produire et publié dans quelques
semaines un travail sur deux UMR de
l'Université de Paris Créteil lien c'est
Paris Créteil lupec nous allons produire
un rapport public dans les jours qui
viennent vous pourrez voir un peu
comment cette grosse université
fonctionne mais nous allons avoir un
focus nous avons un focus sur deux ces
unités qui permettent d'analyser un
petit peu les les et surtout et surtout
ces derniers points nous sommes en train
et c'est grâce à Philippe Rousselot de
rédiger ce que nous apprend une autre
structurel sur la recherche qui est un
peu le pendant de celle qui a été cité à
plusieurs reprises sur les universités
et ça on l'a dévoilé elle est en cours
de contradiction elle est un peu voilà
elle fait un peu de bruit dans le
landerneau
elle insiste je peux me permettre de
dire et Philippe pourrait le compléter
mieux que moi elle assiste beaucoup sur
la mission de recherche d'université et
si je peux prendre un mot qui est sans
doute un peu agressif elle prône un
recentrage de la recherche dans les
universités voilà vous en saurez plus
dans quelques mois j'espère
je vais prendre toutes vos questions
vous demandant évidemment d'être assez
synthétiques vous êtes nombreux à
vouloir intervenir on va commencer par
Pierre ouzouyas merci monsieur le
Président de la Commission merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur pour pour la qualité de votre
rapport qui va vraiment très loin et sur
et sur lequel je le dis avec beaucoup de
sincérité je partage l'essentiel des
bilans des propositions et de la
prospective générale qui me semble
extrêmement intéressante tu peux la la
résumer en une phrase nos sociétés sont
face à des défis qui sont absolument
majeurs tels que l'humanité les a peu
connus jusqu'à présent et vous
considérez nous tous ici que
nous pourrons nous en sortir face à ces
défis grâce à un investissement majeur
dans la connaissance dans la recherche
dans l'intelligence et que pour ça on a
besoin absolument de de tirer vers le
haut toute une classe d'âge pour lui
permettre d'accéder à l'enseignement
supérieur on a besoin de plus de
docteurs on a besoin de doubler le
nombre d'ingénieurs donc c'est c'est des
débits de formation qui sont absolument
majeures et vous et vous dites très
justement que nous ne pourrons pas y
arriver sans repenser l'université comme
un instrument fondamental d'aménagement
du territoire
l'université permettant justement
d'aller chercher ses publics qui sont
aujourd'hui un peu éloignés de
l'université et qui feront toute la
différence dans le sous qualitatif que
que nous devons faire donc vous vous
incitez à un changement de paradigme qui
est fort et que monsieur le Président de
la Commission avait parfaitement exprimé
lors de la mission d'information sur sur
la vie la vie étudiante vous vous
insistez à raison sur le maillage
nécessaire sur l'interaction entre les
univers côté maison mère de métropole et
toutes ces antennes qui permettent de
drainer le public étudiant alors si vous
me permettez une formule un peu un peu
facile aujourd'hui où on nous demande de
bannir TikTok de nos portables parce que
derrière il y a le Parti communiste
chinois moi j'aimerais qu'on fasse la
même chose avec le classement de
Shanghai parce que derrière il y a aussi
le Parti communiste chinois avec un
parangonnage qui me semble aujourd'hui
par rapport à ce que je vous lis
complètement obsolète qui ne correspond
pas à ce que à ce que nous vont faire
votre le changement de paradigme vous
proposez un instrument puissant pour y
aboutir c'est la déconcentration et vous
avez un vrai projet de déconcentration
qui je pense à mon avis permet justement
de redonner toute l'autonomie à
l'université et on comprend bien en vous
lisant que la condition d'une nouvelle
autonomie des universités ça serait une
meilleure déconcentration alors je vous
lis parce
c'est un sénateur communiste qui dit ça
donc ça ça les fait rire je traduis je
traduis voilà
et on sent bien que que dans tout ça il
y a tout le problème de l'évaluation
je remarque dans votre rapport le hcrs
est cité une fois de façon tout à fait
marginale et on comprend bien entre les
lignes que l'évaluation menée par le HCS
bien prend très peu en compte ce qui est
essentiel pour vous c'est-à-dire la
terreur utilisation et la capacité
d'aller chercher les publics donc j'en
viens à ma question et j'en finis là
monsieur le Président comment on
pourrait entrevoir une évaluation qui
permet justement de mieux mesurer
l'évolution dans le changement de de
paradigme le HCR fait un travail mais un
travail d'évaluation scientifique avec
des critères internationaux nous nous
avons besoin d'autres critères qui
permettent justement de mesurer
l'évolution de l'université dans le
système que vous que vous nous dites et
je pense que la proposition que vous
faites pour donner plus de pouvoir au
recteur de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche et à ses délégué je la
trouve absolument fondamentale parce
qu'on voit très bien que c'est dans
cette relation à trois recteur de l'ESR
collectivité et université qu'on pourra
redonner de l'autonomie je remercie Yann
chanterelle
oui merci monsieur le Président je vous
remercie en tout cas pour ce travail
particulièrement rigoureux et minutieux
qui rappelle un certain nombre de
problèmes déjà bien identifié dans notre
universités notamment l'absence générale
de direction dans les différentes
réformes de l'enseignement supérieur
avec des doctrines parfois qui peuvent
être un peu contradictoires
notamment l'alternance entre les
périodes de division et de regroupement
des universités qui rendent le paysage
universitaire français assez éligible
par exemple on ne sait on ne sait pas
parfois plus comment s'appelle les
universités dont on est diplômé je
prends l'exemple par exemple il y a eu
Paris 7 qui est devenu Paris Diderot
après Université de Paris après
Université Paris Cité on peut avoir du
mal un peu à s'y retrouver c'est déjà
compliqué quand on est français donc
imaginé à l'étranger cela peut être
vraiment néfaste pour l'attractivité à
l'international de nos universités vous
rappelez aussi le caractère ob du
dispositif d'allocation de moyens
notamment via le fameux dialogue
stratégique et de gestion qui n'est plus
en phase avec la réalité et à ce titre
ne permet pas de corriger les
différentes inégalités que vous pointez
du doigt et c'est en ça que vous faites
plusieurs observations qu'il est beau de
mettre en avant et de souligner tout
particulièrement vous vous constatez des
écarts particulièrement choquants
inacceptables en matière de réussite
étudiante entre les universités qui
concentrent les plus importants
effectifs de licence taux de réussite au
diplôme de 39% et les universités ou les
effectifs de licence sont moins nombreux
ou là le taux de réussite au diplôme et
de
61%. or il y a justement une corrélation
entre ces taux de réussite et la
composition sociale de ces différents
types d'universités les universités qui
concentrent les plus importants
effectives de licence comptent davantage
d'étudiants défavorisés 27% de boursiers
32% de Basselier technologies qui est
professionnel le 29% et peu d'étudiants
ayant obtenu une mention bien ou très
bien au baccalauréat il représenterait à
peu près donc dans votre rapport 16%. au
contraire les universités les effectifs
de licence sont moins nombreux elles
accueillent bien moins d'étudiants des
favorisés 14 % de boursiers 18 %,
bacheliers technologique 9%, et la
proportion d'étudiants justement qui ont
obtenu bien ou très bien eux sont très
importants c'est 50% alors non seulement
les politiques développées par le
ministère ne corrige pas donc c'est ces
inégalités mais elles les amplifient
souvent donc ma première question elle
porte sur la taille des universités vous
faites des observations descriptives sur
la taille variable des universités mais
peu de remarques normatives on s'est
beaucoup gargariser de vouloir faire du
plateau de Saclay un Cambridge à la
française or c'est un modèle qu'on
retrouve peu en France une université de
taille moyenne c'est-à-dire environ 20
minutes étudiants en de des grandes
métropoles c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve peu alors la question c'est ce
qu'il faut continuer à fusionner nos
universités dans de grandes structures
métropolitaines quitte à kit Taillades
des antennes ou est-ce qu'il nous
faudrait plus d'universités mais moins
grosses après j'aurai une autre une
autre question une deuxième question il
est justement beaucoup question de
périmètre dans votre rapport notamment
dans la définition de ce qu'est une
université mais aussi dans
l'appréhension des enjeux liés à ce
qu'on appelle la vie étudiante vous
faites remarquer que les CROUS ne
s'occupent pas seulement des étudiants
des universités mais de tout
l'enseignement supérieur on peut penser
aux étudiants de classe prépa or
justement vous faites largement
abstraction du système dual
d'enseignement supérieur que nous avons
dans vos analyses alors que pour
beaucoup les étudiants de CPGE ont
vocation à rejoindre l'université et ce
qu'il n'y a aucun impact de la carte et
de la sociologie des CPGE sur les
disparités sociales et géographiques que
vous constatez à l'université est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas lieu de réfléchir à de
meilleurs synergies justement entre les
deux voir un rapprochement
oui merci monsieur le Président moi que
c'est quelques questions précises dans
votre présentation vous nous dites que
vous réjouissez même vous dites que
c'est que 65% de réponses des
universités c'est satisfaisant moi je
trouve que un tiers des universités qui
ne rentrent pas leur copie ça me paraît
plutôt inquiétant et j'aimerais savoir
si c'est plutôt les grosses universités
les petites comment vous analysez la
c'est non-réponses
pour revenir sur la question qui a été
posée sur le regroupement des
universités
moi je suis lu dans le département du
Rhône on a des réflexions sur les les
regroupements des diverses universités
d'ailleurs pour qu'elles soient un petit
peu moins peut-être en silo dans leur
discipline mais qui est plus de brassage
de culture alors j'ai bien entendu les
chiffres de mon voisin sur les résultats
mais est-ce qu'il y a quand même un
intérêt
économique et de gouvernance de
regrouper quelques universités et d'y
adjointe d'ailleurs des antennes ce vous
permettrait parce que votre carte là sur
autour de Lyon c'est quand même très
balant il y a il y a un gros rond
central mais tout le reste est assez
clair et enfin sur les campus connectés
vous nous avez cité l'exemple de campus
connectés avec un seul étudiant est-ce
que vous avez quand même la moyenne des
étudiants
globalement sur ces campus et ce qu'on a
quand même déjà des résultats
d'orientation au bout d'un an deux ans
de fonctionnement parce que moi j'ai des
exemples de de réussite et de
progression d'effectif dans ces campus
connectés
Monique DeMarco je vous remercie moi je
vais aller directement aux questions
dans votre présentation tout à l'heure
au sujet des antennes vous avez dit que
elle pouvait être considérée comme un
coucou supplémentaire j'aurais voulu que
vous précisiez ces propos
concernant les deuxième question
concernant les inégalités territoriales
le taux du diplômé se réduirait à mesure
que l'on s'éloigne des centres-villes
c'est ce que me semble que j'ai compris
avez-vous des préconisations justement
pour réorienter et
et dernière question avez-vous fait un
bilan du mode de financement de
renforcement des financements par appel
à projet
Pierre Antoine Lévy
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président tout d'abord merci pour
pour présentation et votre travail
précis dirige d'enseignement en beaucoup
de choses ont été dites mais dans
d'autres rapports vous reconnaissez le
rôle essentiel joué par les universités
de proximité et leurs antennes alors
c'est vrai que c'est pas un mot c'est
pas un gros mot mais c'est la
dénomination dans le maillage
territorial universitaire ce maillage
constitue un enjeu majeur d'aménagement
du territoire alors dans son rapport
d'information accompagnement des
étudiants une priorité un enjeu d'avenir
pour l'État des collectivités mission
d'informations qu'il est présidée par
notre président Laurent Laffont constaté
que le choix de la proximité est parfois
une condition à l'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur pour de nombreuses étudiants
le critère de proximité géographique est
invoqué dans 80% des cas selon une
enquête réalisée par l'innu Champollion
Albi devant la réputation et le coût de
l'établissement
soutenir le développement d'une offre de
formation universitaire d'excellence
dans le territoire et donc une nécessité
or comme le pointé institut Montaigne en
2021 plus de deux tiers et on l'a vu
deux tiers des étudiants sont concentrés
dans le 22 métropole alors que ces
dernières ne concentrent que 29% de la
population française on constate donc
que développer une offre locale
d'enseignements supérieurs de qualité
est un véritable levier d'attractivité
pour les territoires les collectivités
doivent favoriser une offre diversifiée
et encourager les étudiants à choisir
ses structures
inscrire enseignement supérieur au coeur
des politiques d'aménagement du
territoire peut également représenter
des avantages au niveau économique des
synergies intéressantes peuvent se créer
entre les universités et les entreprises
locales les étudiants pouvant trouver un
premier emploi directement dans les
territoires
on ne peut que regretter que les
initiatives associées en structures
d'enseignement supérieur et entreprises
locales ne soient pas plus systématique
et encouragé par le ministre le
ministère d'enseignement supérieur votre
rapport viennent donc confirmer que les
collectivités et les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur n'ont que des
avantages à créer des synergies ensemble
il faut favoriser les initiatives qui
prouvent encore une fois leur efficacité
merci Sylvie Robert
oui merci monsieur le président
Messieurs Je une petite question qui
concerne le cadre de la
contractualisation entre les
collectivités territoriales vous en avez
parlé autre que les régions d'ailleurs
pour essayer de d'avoir une efficacité
dans le cas de ce de cette gouvernance
partagée il est bien mis dans le code de
l'éducation que les autres collectivités
territoriales concernées peuvent être
associés à l'exercice de
contractualisation est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il faudrait changer la
lettre de la loi et dire qu'elle doivent
être associées parce que l'ensemble des
compétences notamment je pense des
métropoles
peuvent être de fait prise en compte et
puis une deuxième question j'ai été
assez frappé sur la question des entre
des pardons des universités privées
et notamment de l'absence on dirait de
transparence et de clarification à la
fois dans l'installation de ces de ces
universités que l'on voit effectivement
au développement vous le dit vous même
dans dans votre rapport école privée
université est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut il faudrait à la fois avant
de peut-être
travailler certifier les diplômes les
évaluer faire un travail de transparence
de voilà qu'est-ce que vous pensez de de
ce paysage qui évolue beaucoup qui se
modifie et on voit dans tous nos
territoires moi je suis à Rennes encore
deux écoles privées qui viennent de ce
de s'installer
ça rentre dans le paysage forcément
universitaire mais on ne sait absolument
pas en terme de sur le plan financier
d'accessibilité d'organisation des
enseignements comment les choses se
complètent enfin voilà vous avez compris
ma question et j'aimerais que vous
puissiez répondre je vous remercie
beaucoup chaque groupe
merci président monsieur le rapporteur
mais c'est le Président c'est vrai que
ce rapport il devrait en tout cas
permettre aux universités et
collectivités territoriales de mener une
véritable réflexion sur leur intérêt
commun et c'est du sens au Sénat moi je
voudrais dire simplement si les
universités sont des actrices
qu'autournables du développement pardon
économique du territoire France
université l'a dit vous l'avez répété
tout à l'heure qui leur qu'ils auraient
aimé en tout cas que que vous parliez
peut-être un peu plus sur le terrain de
l'autonomie mais si on revient sur
l'autonomie
cette loi en tout cas ce titre qui n'est
pas le vrai titre de la loi de 2007 on
dit souvent le titre c'est l'autonomie
d'université non c'était la Loi relative
ou liberté et responsabilité des
universités donc il faut pas se tromper
le chacun a repris des choses qui lui
permettaient à un moment donné de faire
partie ou de faire parler c'est c'est
propos donc moi j'ai une première
question vous avez ce qui s'est et ça
apparaît sur précurseurs slide le fait
que les présidents que les chefs
d'entreprises ne siègent pas assez dans
l'écossil d'administration diversité
lors de la promulgation de la loi ou
lors des débats de la loi il y avait un
point fort qui était est-ce que les
présidents en disent merci doivent être
des anciens chercheurs ou est-ce qu'ils
doivent être un moment donné aussi des
chefs d'entreprise la ministre a lâché
parce que au départ dans la loi c'était
des chefs d'entreprise qui devaient être
pris dans l'université serait réglé en
partie en problème fort vis-à-vis de
cette gestion et en tout cas de cette
ouverture vous parliez du rapprochement
des CROUS ou parliez la difficulté de la
dévolution également des chefs les
présidents d'universités ne prennent pas
est-ce qu'il sera est-ce que ça pourrait
ne pas être une première recommandation
osons que les présidents que les prisons
universités soient choisis dans le cadre
ou en tout cas chez des chefs
d'entreprise ma deuxième question c'est
sur la contribution financière
les régions sont simplement associées ma
collègue Sylvie Robert poser un problème
important je crois les communautés
urbaines en tout cas où les communautés
d'agglomérations les départements
participent parfois mais pas assez
vis-à-vis de cela et elles sont
simplement associées mais elles sont pas
véritablement parties prenantes dans en
tout cas dans dans le choix de l'offre
universitaire alors cette question cette
question est simple c'est comment
répondre à la demande des régions
d'occuper une place renforcée bon les
agissent essentiellement au niveau des
formations sanitaires et puis enfin
comme dans les Linder d'ailleurs et vous
le dites dans votre rapport et enfin une
troisième question c'est la question des
petites universités qui ont été question
qui a été un propos qui a été engagé
tout à l'heure par un des présidents qui
disait que les universités de moins de
20 000 habitants avaient des difficultés
financières moi je vois dans la région
de Bourgoin de Franche-Comté il y a une
commune qui s'est mise en place avec
Bourgogne Franche-Comté il y a eu une
scission de cette commune uniquement
pour le la difficulté de savoir où on
trouvait le siège de la commune là je
m'interroge sur le rôle directeurs qui
sont en charge du ministère
nationalement supérieur et ce qui
devrait pas avoir une fonction
importante de pouvoir taper le point sur
la table parce qu'on voit que ce sont
des financements qui disparaissent près
de 10 millions d'euros pour les uns les
autres dans le cadre du site voilà tel
était mais trois questions je vous
remercie président deux dernières
questions Nathalie Delattre et ensuite
Sonia de la pauvreté
merci monsieur le Président je rebondis
sur
sur une phrase que vous avez eu tout à
l'heure dans vos propos de présentation
en parlant de la problématique des
logements vacants pendant la période
estivale alors nous ne devons pas
connaître les mêmes campus effectivement
parce que à Bordeaux je suis sénatrice
de la Gironde il y a 8 étudiants pour un
logement et l'été les étudiants sont
pleins de peur de laisser leur logement
étudiants donc il y a peu de peu de
tornover
et effectivement cela pose d'ailleurs de
graves problèmes de rénovation de ces
logements puisque les temps
d'intervention sont donc réduits et dès
que l'on enlève des logements du parc et
bien effectivement ce sont des étudiants
qui ne sont pas accueillis
à cette occasion moi je suis allée
visiter des logements qui qui était en
mauvais état le CROUS effectivement
assure les travaux courants mais pour
beaucoup ces logements sont propriétés
des bailleurs sociaux qui ont beaucoup
de mal à faire les gros travaux et donc
je voulais savoir si dans vos travaux
alors vous allez vous annoncer cette
bonne nouvelle de voir un rapport
spécifique sur le logement étudiant
j'espère que vous pourrez en faire une
présentation ici parce que
cette question est très très importante
est-ce que vous aurez des préconisations
sur le fait qu'il y a peut-être une
nouvelle forme de
d'aide à avoir en faveur de ces CROUS
alors je suis comme vous favorable à
cette incréditération et cette gestion
directe par les universités mais cela
implique de pouvoir être propriétaire de
ces logements parce que
le rapport propriétaire bailleur sociaux
et locataire CROUS et compliqué encore
une fois dans sa gestion des petits
travaux et aider gros travaux donc voilà
je voulais avoir votre sentiment en la
matière si vous pouvez déjà nous
annoncer un peu les conclusions de ce
rapport qui devrait être imminent et
puis aussi une dernière question je pose
tout à l'heure en question en
gouvernement
une question sur la santé mentale des
jeunes vous n'avez absolument pas parlé
de l'accompagnement psychologique des
jeunes qui aussi quand on parle
d'université un paramètre énorme à
prendre en compte aujourd'hui tant leur
détresse psychologique et grande merci
Sonia de la pauvreté
oui merci beaucoup ma première question
va porter sur sur l'autonomie
parce qu'on a du mal à mettre un contenu
précis sur ce sujet et on sait pas quand
elle s'applique et quand elle s'efface
parce qu'il peut être nécessaire qu'elle
s'efface et j'en veux pour preuve la
mise en place de la réforme d'accès aux
études de santé qui a vu fleurir en
France une réforme par université avec
une forte inégalité de très très grande
disparité or me semble-t-il un médecin
reste un médecin et par la suite
d'ailleurs les enseignements sont
beaucoup plus normés et donc est apparu
à la faveur de cette réforme une un vrai
problème de pilotage national d'alerte
voire de cadrage
n'empêchant pas l'autonomie des
universités mais permettant quand même
que sur cette objective majeur d'intérêt
public et de santé publique on puisse
rec de la bonne façon des étudiants pour
devenir médecin et professionnels de
santé demain donc je voulais avoir votre
votre point de vue sur ce lien entre
l'autonomie et aussi la nécessité d'un
pilotage quand il s'est agit d'avoir des
chiffres nationaux on en a pas eu et on
en a toujours pas d'ailleurs sur la
réussite des objectifs notamment le
pluralisme de recrutement dans les dans
les promotions
mon autre question porte sur le poste
covid et ce qui avait été mis en
évidence ce fameux enseignement à faire
à faible valeur ajoutée descendant
magistral qui est celui de
l'amphithéâtre et on avait mis en
évidence que justement les enseignants
les enseignements plus interactifs en
petits groupes dirige ed TD qui sont qui
relèvent du mentorat du tutorat était
intéressant et que la numérisation
pouvait pour le coup servir plutôt à
faire les enseignements magistraux et
c'était une très grosse opportunité pour
les territoires et la décentralisation
est-ce que vous avez regardé cet aspect
là parce que pour le coup les
collectivités territoriales seraient
très allante pour pouvoir accompagner
justement ces enseignements dirigés
favorisés parce que dans les antennes
c'est beaucoup plus facile à mettre en
place ma troisième question porte sur
parcoursup vous avez dit
qu'effectivement qui avait une
répartition des balles des bacheliers
très différents entre le siège et les
antennes au niveau social et au niveau
de la réussite est-ce que vous pensez
que l'absence de transparence ou en tout
cas des choix et des algorithmes locaux
et le fait que chaque université mettre
le sien en place à aggraver cette
différence entre la répartition entre le
siège et les antennes en d'autres termes
les meilleurs bacheliers sont choisis
préférentiellement parcoursup pour aller
dans le dans le siège et enfin
ma quatrième question a déjà été un peu
évoquée c'est celle des regroupements au
forceps les fusions absorption les opéa
d'un site sur un autre pour faire des
universités
reconcentrer on le sait très bien il y a
les endroits où ça s'est fait et ça
marche mal désormais je me citerai pas
le lieu mais tout le monde le sait et
les aides de l'État et de certaines
collectivités d'ailleurs proactives
conditionne son conditionnées à cette
fusion absorption est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est indispensable et qu'il vaut
mieux pas que finalement les sites
marchent bien et travaillent bien
ensemble voilà je voudrais rajouter une
dernière question et évidemment elle
s'adresse aux membres de la Cour des
comptes que vous êtes
vous avez beaucoup insisté dans le
rapport sur la réelle occasion des
moyens ou les disparités plus exactement
entre les les allocations des
différentes universités
à enveloppe constante ça paraît
difficile de rééquilibrer les choses
est-ce que vous avez fait une évaluation
ne serait-ce que pour la partie contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens et performance
du supplément nécessaire pour arriver à
ce changement de paradigme que cité
notamment Pierre ouzouillas c'est que
vous sur lequel vous insistez également
dans votre rapport
vous répartir peut-être les réponses
vous avez vu que les questions sont
nombreuses je ne sais pas dans quel
ordre vous voulez les prendre je me
permets juste de dire avant que mon
collègue le temps de répondre à la
plupart de vos questions avec le
concours de Clément que vous nous avez
donné là pratiquement soit la matière
d'une journée entière d'étude soit même
d'un mandat de travail qu'un canal donc
voilà nous on peut pas répondre à fond
mais tous ces notons bien toutes ces
questions et naturellement au-delà de ce
que j'ai dit nous y travaillons et nous
pourrons vous apporter des réponses dans
les dans les mois qui viennent
oui sur le point précis Morgan me
rappelle que vous avez évoqué madame la
réforme des études de médecine alors de
santé mais nous faisons nous avons une
enquête en cours sur le sujet voilà donc
dans quelques mois sur la
la toi ne rapportons les ont repéré et
voilà nous en y travaillons et j'espère
que
voilà voilà absolument merci beaucoup
comment
de réflexion pour reprendre les les
notes
on nous
essaye de répondre
sur la faire des 65%
notre satisfaction était d'ordre
statistique
elle n'était pas évidemment nous on est
on aurait préféré 100% pourquoi
certaines universités nous répondent pas
en général c'est parce que elles
estiment ne pas avoir le temps
des autres choses à faire
je dirais même que 65% c'est une bonne
c'est un bon résultat dans les habitudes
que nous avons comme nous adressons nos
questionnaires à toutes les universités
ce que nous faisons assez
systématiquement dans nos contrôles
donc je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
pas c'est
non non alors là il n'y a pas de non
alors sur la taille de l'université et
si je peux me permettre essayer de la
lier à la problématique des fusions et
absorption même si cette expression
c'est très difficile parce que de vos
réponses parce que
et je pense pas qu'il y a un idéal type
autre que celui de
ce que le territoire et son université
décide d'être eux-mêmes je j'aime
toujours citer la phrase d'un des
présidents d'universités les plus
célèbres du monde qui était Suisse à
Lausanne et qui disait pour moi une
université c'est 10000 étudiants et un
milliard d'euros
alors moi j'aime assez cette définition
parce qu'au moins lui c'est ce qu'il
veut mais je pense que vous parliez du
classement de Shanghai les grandes
universités du haut du classement ne
sont pas des grosses universités en
effectif donc ça mérite sans doute un
moment de réflexion
big is not beautiful
mais c'était pas la cour qui va décider
de ça alors
ce qu'il y a c'est qu'il y a des textes
notamment la loi de 2013 qui a imposé
aux universités de faire le choix de la
fusion de la commu ou de l'association
Toutes ne l'ont pas fait certaines sont
restées orphelines volontairement
et puis après il y a eu l'ordonnance sur
les établissements expérimentaux où là
il y a eu des absorptions et des fusions
comme pour employer cette expression
qui ont pour caractéristiques d'être
mené dans la plus totale liberté
et
alors les résultats
il nous faudra quand même un peu de
temps pour pour les
les évaluer de manière approfondie il
est normal que lorsque des grandes
manœuvres de cette nature se mettent en
branle il y a une période de confusion
une période de difficulté initiale de
mise en place dès qu'ils proposent il
faut laisser du temps à ces
établissements étant entendu que les
établissements expérimentaux ne
l'oublions surtout pas pour vocation à
peine cachée de tous devenir des grands
établissements
et que certaines
établissements expérimentaux aujourd'hui
entame leur procédure de fin de
l'expérimentation pour passer à un autre
statut ce qui fait que le tableau qui
est dans le rapport il est déjà faux
avant même d'avoir été imprimé
tout ça va encore beaucoup bouger
jusqu'à présent la Cour ne s'est pas
prononcée sur les effets de taille
autrement que en les constatant et à la
préférée travailler sur
la notion de grande université à
rayonnement international et recherche
intensive
qui sont assez faciles à identifier
puisqu'elle s'identifie elle-même
au sein d'une association où on ne
rentre pas comme ça
toutes les universités peuvent sonner à
la porte de l'association on y rentre
pas si facilement bon nous on va pas
rentrer dans ce détail là il y a
manifestement des universités qui sont
IDEX et ici
qui constituerait
modulo 1 ou 2 cas particuliers une
catégorie d'université et vous voyez
qu'ici je parle pas de la taille et je
ne parle pas
de sa superficie qui est un autre
problème
et puis il y aurait des universités
oula le rayonnement est la recherche
sont moindres moins intensifs mais on
n'a pas dit de moindre qualité on a dit
de moins de moindre intensité et c'est
la fameuse théorie finalement pas
y recevable du tout de la recherche de
niche de la spécialité certaines
universités littorales ont parfaitement
réussi ou du moins on relevé ce défi
avec des arguments bon La Rochelle mais
même à Toulon on voit des le même type
de raisonnement qui qui se met en place
et c'est heureux en montagne aussi
Chambéry donc
il restera toujours après des questions
sans réponse sur certaines universités
qui n'ont pas la taille critique pour
être de grands rayonnement international
mais qui souhaitent toujours l'être
voilà donc sur l'effet de taille nous ce
que nous voyons c'est les conséquences
et les conséquences ça me permet de
rebondir sur une autre question c'est
celui de l'immobilier on en a pas parlé
dans ce travail là mais l'immobilier
et ça me permet de faire écho aussi à
une autre question c'est profondément
lié selon la Cour à la notion
d'autonomie
quand vous êtes locataire vous n'êtes
pas autonome voilà la position de la
Cour
ou pour le dire mieux comme vous le
disiez vous-même tout à l'heure
lorsqu'on n'est pas propriétaire
donc la Cour estime qu'il y a un lien
profond entre d'évolution et autonomie
et donc en étant dans la question à
celle que vous posiez tout à l'heure
concernant les CROUS voilà l'idée de
base mais qui est une idée qui demande à
vivre sur la très longue durée c'est pas
une idée pour être qui doit être réalisé
dans les mois qui viennent c'est une
affaire d'année d'expérimentation de de
politique du pas à pas il faut être
prudent et ne pas violenter les
personnels naturellement il faut aller à
la bonne vitesse je pense que les
universités propriétaires seront
forcément plus autonomes c'est en tout
cas quand je dis je c'est excusez-moi
c'est la cour
sur la base de ces travaux intérieurs
oui madame sur Madame c'est triste sur
les la problématique des initiales cités
privées des écoles privées donc nous
avons ici uniquement focalisé sur les
universités privées Clément je parle sur
votre contrôle
il y en a pas de temps que ça
et donc on a simplement remarqué que les
universités privées bien connues
et sur lesquels on a on ne se prononce
pas autrement que ça
n'ayant pas le droit de délivrer
elle-même leur diplôme le font par le
biais d'une convention avec une autre
université mais que ce qu'on a remarqué
c'est que dans la ville V qui est une
grande ville vous avez une grande
université catholique et une grande
université publique et que c'est pas
avec c'est pas entre ces deux
universités que se font les agréments et
les conventions c'est avec l'Université
de PV la petite ville qui est à 50 km
voilà et donc ça nous a paru être un
manque de transport et d'autre part
d'après les textes il n'y a pas lieu que
l'université privée s'appelle université
pour les écoles nous n'y avons pas
touché c'est une autre affaire bien plus
compliquée je crois
car multiple et en effet il y a il y a
école privée il y a école privée sous
contrat et tout ça est très varié et il
faudra qu'on que la Cour ils reviennent
sans doute mais là vous comprenez que en
ayant fait le choix très restreint de
l'université nous n'avons pas du tout
prospéré sur cette voie
sur le bilan des financements des AAP
alors ça c'est assez difficile
aujourd'hui de vous faire un tableau
sous l'angle du présent de rapport
c'est-à-dire de la territorialité on
peut on peut on peut on peut assez bien
parler de des AP qui sont de type
différents
mais surtout ne jamais oublier payer à
au pluriel parce que entre le premier et
le quatrième c'est pas du tout la même
chose de France 2030
du plan de relance
et d'autres acteurs car il faut pas
oublier qu'il y a de nombreux acteurs
autres qui font des appels à projets
donc clément nous sur la partie
territoriale qu'est-ce qu'on a dit sur
cette affaire de la paix
donc sur la question des appels à
projets ce qu'on a constaté vous l'avez
vu tout à l'heure c'est de la carte qui
qui indique bien sûr une des disparités
de financement de façon territoriale et
en fait c'était c'était depuis le départ
l'ambition assumée des investissements
d'avenir de créer des universités
championnes qui rayonne à
l'international qui concentre une partie
importante des financements pour pouvoir
peser au plus haut niveau dans la dans
la recherche mondiale donc je pense que
le bilan territorial qu'on a pu qu'on a
pu dresser il est il est essentiellement
ici
je peux poursuivre quelqu'un a parlé du
classement de Shanghai
pour le classement de Shanghai à mon
avis a beaucoup perdu de sa de sa force
depuis quelques années maintenant si
j'ai bien compris le classement de
Shanghai a été créé par des pour
répondre à une question très simple
c'est où dois-je envoyer mes enfants
pour qu'il fasse les meilleures études
possibles cette question nous n'avons
pas rencontré en France de parents
d'élèves qui se la pose en ces termes en
prenant le classement de Shanghai comme
référence il se la pose bien évidemment
tous les jours mais le classement de
Shanghai n'est pas leur bréviaire et la
plupart d'entre eux ne le connaissent
pas le classement de Shanghai a
constitué je reviens pas là-dessus un
choc quand il est paru dans sa troisième
édition et il a été à l'origine de
nombreux bouleversements aux alentours
des années 2007 mais il n'a jamais
pénétré la société française notamment
le monde des parents d'élèves auprès de
qui
il
devait trouver toute son originalité
toute sa vocation il a été plutôt
concentré dans le microcosme où chacun
s'est demandé pourquoi il était pas 400e
ou 35e
donc voilà je pense que c'est un sujet
qui est maintenant un peu derrière nous
vous nous avez demandé comment faire
pour que le hcer
général comment faire pour mieux évaluer
les changements de paradigme ça j'ai pas
la réponse toute faite sans doute
faudrait-il que
le VHS reçoivent Amanda pour
évaluer ces questions de territorialité
prise une fois de plus dans leur dans
leur globalité et sans oublier la
recherche ou bien on peut aussi
imaginer qu'il y ait des instances
d'évaluation
spécialisées sur cette question et pour
l'instant il n'y en a pas
vous nous avez peut-être
légèrement exagéré la portée de nos
conclusions en disant que nous étions
pour un renforcement
du niveau académique et notamment du
réacteur délégué nous avons surtout
demandé que l'on clarifie
sa position parce que commençons par là
parce que sincèrement
c'est flou c'est incertain sortons de
cette situation et après il sera
toujours temps de voir si c'était une
bonne idée ou une mauvaise au fil au fil
de l'expérience
[Musique]
oui prenez un peu allez-y
alors il y a eu différentes questions
sur les campus connectés donc on m'a
demandé
demander si donc le chiffre de 110.000
euros pour les deux campus qui n'ont
accueilli qu'un seul étudiant a été
avancé on m'a demandé s'il y avait le
chiffre moyen donc le chiffre moyen est
de 13000 euros pour vous donner un point
de comparaison un étudiant en licence à
l'université c'est environ 5000 euros
donc là on est quand même quasiment
quasiment au tripes sachant que cette
étudiant est
et qui suit un enseignement à distance
et aussi inscrit dans une autre
université donc on pourrait considérer
qui qui coûte en fait 13000 euros en
plus de sa licence qui suit à distance
donc c'est vraiment un coup c'est
vraiment un coup important est-ce qu'il
y a des exemples de réussite de campus
connectés il y a des campus connectés
qui accueillent des étudiants il y a des
il y a certains campus connectés qui on
pourrait dire qui marche plutôt bien les
les populations étudiantes qui même si
on n'a pas pu analyser à ce point de
détails les campus connectés les
populations étudiantes sont assez
surprenantes il y a beaucoup de sportifs
de haut niveau donc c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on aurait forcément attendu des
parents célibataires des gens souffrant
de de pathologies
qu'on constate c'est que on ne sait pas
en fait à quoi servent ces campus
connectés est-ce que c'est pour financer
le sport au niveau le MSR a créé des
campus connectés je crois pas que
c'était l'idée à l'origine
et l'autre point
l'autre point que l'on constate sur ces
sur ces campus connectés c'est il n'y a
pas eu de comparaison avec qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait faire avec 13000 euros
pour un étudiant à l'université sans
avoir à créer un nouveau lieu est-ce que
mettre en place du tutorat à
l'université ça pour avoir du sens aussi
sans avoir à le faire dans une dans un
campus spécifique
ces trucs Clément je parle souvent de
contrôle mais une des particularités du
campus connecté c'est que si vous êtes
inscrit dans le campus connecté de la
ville de V ça ne veut où se trouve
l'université ça ne veut pas dire que
vous passerez votre diplôme de cette
université vous pouvez très bien dans un
campus connecté passez votre diplôme
dans une université éloignée d'ailleurs
c'est le but de la connexion et de ce
fait ça explique une partie du
désintérêt des universités pour cet
objet
qui ne leur apporte beaucoup moins
qu'elle le pourrait l'espérer dans la
mesure où un assez grand nombre
d'étudiants se connectent en vue
d'obtenir un diplôme ailleurs que dans
l'université de l'endroit où se situe
des matériels
voire même vos compléter ce que vous
dites Philippe dans une voire même dans
une école privée des étudiants qui sont
inscrits dans les campus connectés et
qui suivent les cours de formation
privée il y a eu une question sur le
coup d'un étudiant en dans une antenne
on m'a demandé pourquoi est-ce que ce
coup est perçu comme un coup
supplémentaire et bien en fait c'est
parce que le
scarabée notre enquête c'est que il n'y
a pas dans la subvention pour charge de
service public des crédits qui sont
dédiés aux étudiants dans les antennes
donc si l'université veut ouvrir une
nouvelle formation dans une antenne elle
doit s'acquitter de frais
supplémentaires donc des bâtiments des
frais de transport pour les pour les
enseignants et c'est des frais
supplémentaires qu'elle n'a pas dans le
siège
si on calcule le coût complet si on
regarde combien ça coûte une fois que
tu auras comme ça coûte de faire cette
formation c'est le
on mesure que le coût est similaire en
antenne et à l'université mais
l'université est obligé d'aller chercher
des financements supplémentaires pour
financer cette nouvelle antenne qui
correspond pour elle à des coûts
supplémentaires parce qu'elle n'est pas
pris en compte dans la subvention pour
charge de service public
quelques compléments par rapport à mes
collègues je veux je vais très vite pour
respecter votre votre agenda je reviens
sur la question de l'évaluation la
question sénateur aux ulias en réalité
pour mieux prendre en compte l'animation
territoriale dans l'évaluation je ne
suis pas et c'est une position
personnelle à la Cour n'a pas écrit
là-dessus favorable à ce qu'on ajoute
des critères dans l'émission c'est à
dire qu'en fait dans les six missions
d'université nous disions qu'il y a
celle de l'insertion professionnelle
donc la qualité de l'assembolutionnaire
permet déjà de voir y compris dans un
bassin comment fonctionne l'université
et l'autre c'est quand même aussi la
qualité de la vie étudiante que vous
avez bien étudié c'est à dire que les
indices de satisfaction des étudiants
font partie aussi de la l'appréciation
de la performance de l'université sur
sur le point le point qui était évoqué
par Madame De Marco et qui a été bloqué
par les collègues sur les appels à
projets bon on va dire un chose de plus
sauf que vous le savez si vous procédez
vous-même à des auditions nous étions
avec le président de France université
la semaine dernière il y a véritablement
une fatigue des appels au projet une
faillite université qui estime dépenser
beaucoup de temps je ne peux pas nous
pouvons pas le chiffre à ce stade voilà
donc on est on est dans une logique de
réflexion sur le bien fondé nous en
reparlerons cette demande à d'autres
travaux sur la question de du sénateur
Lévy sur le la question du du de la
concentration de l'iPad c'est la
question du logement et bien on peut pas
malheureusement notre travail n'est même
pas comment c'est je l'ai annoncé pour
faire un peu de teasing mais c'est une
production une évaluation que nous
produirons l'année prochaine l'année
prochaine bon mais on voit bien enfin
intuitivement n'ont pas encore pas
présenté des travaux on voit bien qu'il
y a des synergies à trouver à renforcer
entre justement
le dispositif des CROUS etc mais aussi
le rôle des collectivités territoriales
en matière de logements social les OPH
représentent plus vous le savez bien ici
plus de la moitié du logement social je
ne suis pas sûr enfin on pourrait ouvrir
une réflexion sur la notion vous savez
de commission d'attribution d'emplois
essentiels etc et de savoir si dans les
attributions de logements les étudiants
doivent être traités d'une manière
particulière ou pas c'est une question
que je pose et on essaiera d'y réfléchir
plus tard sur la question de
l'Association des collectivités
territoriales aux conventionnement à la
contractualisation bon là aussi position
personnelle mais vous souvenez que les
collectivités territoriales toutes
ensemble toutes catégories financent
l'enseignement supérieur à hauteur d'à
peu près 2 milliards de milliards c'est
7 à 8% du budget que j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure alors dans cette proportion là
naturellement il est normal qu'il est
inconventionnement c'est financement
doivent trouver une un support de
croisement au-delà c'est plutôt une
association à mon avis qu'il faut qu'il
faut envisager sur la question
j'en ai plus que deux sur la question du
manque de chiffres que posait madame de
la pauvreté moi je suis frappé et je
suis un débutant pardonnez-moi je suis
frappé par la faiblesse de la mission
centrale la faiblesse j'ai rencontré la
directrice de la DGC il y a quelques
jours du service statistique ministériel
on pourra peut-être y regarder et je
crois comprendre qu'on est même pas
capable de compter les étudiants donc
voilà donc on peut aller dans votre
direction on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
pour se doter et pourquoi c'est
important et je me permets ainsi de
répondre à la question du président
Lafont qui nous interpellait sur la
question du niveau de moyens raisonnable
alors d'abord je crois qu'il appartient
vraiment pas à la cour de terminer c'est
à vous un niveau un niveau de de
financement
métier mais simplement rappelons que
nous avons un financement de
l'enseignement supérieur qui est en part
de ping inférieur à la moyenne de l'eau
cede donc c'est un indice bon et
deuxièmement et ça a été évoqué par mes
collègues aussi au delà des antennes que
la dépense par étudiant décroît la
dépense par étudiant décroît depuis des
années donc c'est un indication alors et
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit mettre
comme une sorte d'efficience
supplémentaire voilà alors simplement le
pour conclure tout à fait là c'est je
crois la Cour des comptes qui parle tout
financement supplémentaire toute
contracter donc les comptes notamment
devaient être assortis à nos yeux et
nous aurons l'occasion de le dire d'un
renforcement de la qualité de gestion
car il faut quand même le dire devant
vous il y a une qualité de gestion qui
est globalement insatisfaisante et qui
est très inégale il y a des versets qui
sont bien gérées mais ce que nous voyons
université par université c'est qu'il y
a des effort et donc si des moyens
supplémentaires sont alloués si on veut
plus attentif à la performance il faudra
aussi trouver un système pour que par
exemple le contrôle interne pour être
technique dans l'université se développe
et soit au niveau de de des moyens qui
sont investis
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup messieurs pour toutes ces
réponses à cette problématique vous avez
vu qui interroge beaucoup de intérêt
surtout beaucoup de
sénateurs membres de la commission
l'avait lancé un certain nombre de
pistes explorateurs je ne doute pas que
nous aurons à revenir dessus dans les
mois à venir en tout cas nous serons
très attentifs à la suite de vos travaux
tel que vous les avez présenté merci
beaucoup
je vais demander à mes collègues de
rester puisque nous avons un deuxième
point à l'ordre du jour et je vais
appeler Jean agré pour qu'il vienne
présenter